jacqueline tesarek ist sauer
die 18 jährige will den autoführerschein
machen doch ihre körpergröße von 145 cm
steht ihr da offenbar im weg die austria
fahrschule sind die eltern sich
definitiv nicht für kleinere menschen
weil ich meine wenn man so einen
riesigen suv oder mit riesigen erziele
sagen geh oder sonst irgendwas hat oder
selbst ein porsche haben wenn man
gesehen
nach einer fahrschule und das ist
überhaupt nicht geeignet für so was die
angehende tierpflegerin soll auf wunsch
des straßenverkehrsamtes ein verkehrs
medizinisches gutachten vorlegen dass
ihre fahrtüchtigkeit bestätigt das
gutachten würde locker 1000 euro
zusätzlich für die junge frau bedeuten
der fahrschule sind aufgrund der
anforderungen der behörde die hände
gebunden solange nicht fahren lassen
sich halt so ein gutachten habe weil
sonst die das nicht genehmigen
dabei würde eine schlichte pedal
verlängerung durchaus ausreichend meint
jacqueline im familieneigenen ceat hätte
sie keinerlei probleme an die pedale zu
kommen
auch keine behinderung ich bin ja
eigentlich so sagen topfit auch
kräftemäßig hier
ich habe ja früher oft vier jahre lang
judo gemacht habe an wettkämpfen und
turnieren teilgenommen
also daran mangelt es nicht
auch ihre mutter violet tesarek kann
nicht verstehen warum ihre tochter von
den behörden regelrecht diskriminiert
wird aufgrund der körpergröße
ich würde es verstehen wenn sie eine
erkrankung hätte medikamente nehmen
würde oder drogenabhängig gewesen wäre
oder irgendwas dass man dann wirklich
ein gutachten braucht wo man sagt gut
sie ist eine gefährdung für den verkehr
aber das ist sie nicht sie hat nix und
da finde ich ist das ein bisschen
übertrieben was der staat und und die
ganzen behörden mit uns machen
nicht einmal ein attest des hausarztes
würde ausreichen sind wir mit diesen
gutachten zur fahrschule
wir haben eine gefunden entweder box
rede
und die haben das abgegeben nach
rotenburg und rotenburg hat aber gesagt
nee das würde nicht ausreichen
ein klassischer fall also für bild
kämpft ja und natürlich erstmal für
arndt kempgens erkennt sich mit verkehrs
sachen wird sehr gut aus ist da auch ein
absoluter spezialist ja da will eine
junge frauen führerschein machen und das
scheitert dann an solchen behörden
regelungen wie schätzen sie den fall ein
also der fall ist wirklich total
spannend man muss auf der einen seite
sehen den teilhabe anspruch hier der der
fahrschülerin und wir haben auch
gleichbehandlungs grundsätze wir haben
antidiskriminierungsgesetze gerade was
auch hier die körpergröße anbelangt und
natürlich muss da einen zugang gewährt
werden andererseits hat die behörde
allerdings auch eine verpflichtung eine
überprüfung vorzunehmen wenn aus deren
sicht tatsachen für eine nichteignung
vorliegen das kann übrigens jeden
treffen sogar wenn man schon
führerschein hat und da sind
irgendwelche tatsachen werden bekannt
ich sag mal als beispiel eine diabetes
erkrankung oder eine herzerkrankung oder
beispielsweise eine schlafapnoe das ist
so eine schlaf erkrankung wenn das der
behörde bekannt wird dann muss die
behörde das überprüfen also ein
medizinisches gutachten beispielsweise
aufgeben und ähnlich ist der fall
gelagert wir haben hier einen erstantrag
und da will die behörde das überprüfen
weil ihr aufgrund der körpergröße der
meinung sind hier liegt möglicherweise
nichteignung vor
und dann ist das immer so eine
einzelfall frage ob die behörde das
jetzt prüfen darf ja oder nein ob diese
zweifel an der fahreignung berechtigt
sind ja oder nein ich meine was wir
gehört haben eher nein aber man muss
sich dann tatsächlich auch fragen was
mache ich jetzt wenn das jetzt
verweigert wird dieses diese
begutachtung dann wird die behörde sei
natürlich zu keinen führerschein
dann kann man das natürlich einklagen
klageverfahren dauert naja sagen wir mal
ein halbes jahr und das ist natürlich
ewig lange
deshalb ist es in solchen fällen zwar
blöd wenn man so gut
machen muss aber es ist einfach
einfacher wenn man also der meinung ist
mannschaft das gutachten gutachten bitte
machen dann kriegt man auch den
führerschein
wenn man da bin nicht einverstanden ist
klageweg dauert aber eben länger ist das
denn wirklich ein typischer fall von
diskriminierung wie sehen sie das als
jurist also ich sag mal so
diskriminierung ist ja dann der fall
wenn man aufgrund einer körperlichen
beeinträchtigung benachteiligt wird oder
beispielsweise aufgrund einer religiösen
zugehörigkeit eines politischen
religiösen glaubens wenn man da
irgendwie benachteiligt wird oder
aufgrund des alters das ist dann
klassische diskriminierung da hat man
einen gleichbehandlungs anspruch der ist
gesetzlich sogar verbrieft wenn aber
diese ungleichbehandlung wenn die
sachlich gerechtfertigt ist dann ist das
eben keine unsachliche
ungleichbehandlung sondern dann ist das
eine sachliche ungleichbehandlung und
dann ist das in ordnung aber sie sehen
das ist immer so ein bisschen sonne
gratwanderung im einzelfall kann es also
zulässig sein
da habe ich in diesem fall jetzt zweifel
aber eben da muss man wirklich sich das
noch mal genauer ansehen und auch die
vorgaben noch mal genauer ansehen ich
würde hier der zuschauerin eigentlich
empfehlen so blöd das auch ist und wenn
die behörde nicht freiwillig bereit ist
davon zurück zu gehen dann würde ich
versuchen dieses gutachten zu erstellen
dann geht es einfach schneller
und das ist natürlich auch wichtig wenn
jetzt die junge frau dass sie ihren
führerschein haben will und wir lassen
auch diesen fall noch mal zusammen also
ganz wichtig tatsächlich der behörden
überprüfung in diesem einzelfall kann
zulässig sein
es geht natürlich darum ob die junge
frau auch zum fahren geeignet ist und an
champions hat es gesagt natürlich kann
ich rechtsmittel einlegen aber das
verzögert natürlich den ganzen weg dann
zum führerschein